hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down all the latest
in the mha manga including deku turning
his back
on class 1a as he remains stubbornly
determined to stay
a lone wolf vigilante even if that means
physically confronting his former
classmates
this was such an emotional chapter that
froppy moment at the end
man let's talk about it before we get
into it a quick thank you to nab new for
sponsoring this video
nab is my new favorite online spot for
finding fandom products
it's a super cool website that pools all
the new listings for your favorite
products together
in one place instead of having to search
through dozens of different websites you
can just use nab
as your one stop shop for all the new
releases hard to find restocks
and more whether you're into manga
figures toys
trading cards games or other fandom gear
nab lets you
follow all your favorites on your own
custom page so you never miss
an important new release nab makes it
easy to compare prices
find items that are out of stock and
locate the specific item that you are
looking for
right now for every 100 people who sign
up for a free nab account
one person will win a 50 gift card
go sign up and tell your friends to sign
up too just click the top link
down in the description the more people
enter the more gift
cards they're going to give away so
click that link right now
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution
you have been warned the previous
chapter
ended with deku telling his friends to
get out of his way
and a confrontation between him and
class 1a seemed
imminent in my previous video i
speculated that deku wouldn't fight his
classmates head on
instead he would try to get away from
them and that is exactly what ends up
happening in this chapter
bakugou says that he knows about deku's
new quirks and he tells deku that he
looks like a completely different person
especially with that mask but it is
clear that bakugou
isn't going to back down and neither are
the rest of deku's classmates
deku thanks his classmates for coming he
knows that they are here because they
want to help him but
right after thanking them deku activates
smokescreen
in an attempt to get away the class 1a
crew
seems to have expected this they know
that this is the sixth user's quirk
and they immediately spring into action
in order to locate deku
and stop him from getting away bakugo
uses his quirk to blow the smoke away
and then koda seems to get a bunch of
birds to straight up kamikaze themselves
into deku in order to slow him down koda
calls out to deku and tells him that he
can come back
even nezu said that he can come back so
he has to stop
running away but unlike koda and some of
the others
bakugou doesn't try to appeal to
sentimentality
bakugou is not happy that deku didn't
even talk to his fellow classmates
before he left
and he thinks that deku's growing power
has made him think that he's the main
character and everyone else
is an extra in the story this is
literally true though
but i guess bakugo wouldn't know that so
we can't blame him for being upset
jaku then uses black whip to pull
himself away from those kamikaze birds
and that's when sero steps in and he
tries to restrain deku using his
tape quirk this is actually a funny
situation since black whip is so often
compared to sero's quirk
and both of the quirks were clearly
inspired by spider-man so it was cool to
see the two of them going up against
each other even if it was
very brief the other students step in as
well including jiro
ojiro tokoyami kaminari sato momo
and shoji they're all trying to subdue
deku in various ways
because their mission is to ensure his
safety
even if that means restraining him by
force as they confront deku
they all try to remind him of a moment
in which he made an important
impact on their lives they are trying to
appeal to the bond that they share with
deku as
his friends and his classmates but
no matter what the other students say or
do deku refuses to stay down
he tells his classmates that all for one
is coming after him
and he has to leave for that very reason
if he doesn't leave he will put everyone
close to him
in imminent danger and so deku keeps
struggling
he keeps breaking out of every makeshift
restraint that the other students create
and he keeps pushing forward tokuyam
even attempts to wrap deku
inside a dark shadow generated cocoon a
move that tokoyami says was inspired by
deku himself but even that is not enough
to restrain
our incredibly stubborn protagonist he
manages to break free yet again
and he tells his classmates that he's
fine even though he clearly doesn't
look fine after he escapes from dark
shadows cocoon
deku's mask symbolically flies off
revealing his tortured
facial expression to some extent deku
was trying to hide
behind that mask it was easier for him
to turn away from his friends while the
mask was
protecting him the mask was hiding his
facial expression
from his friends and it allowed him to
maintain his new
lone wolf vigilante persona but when the
mask flies off
everything inevitably becomes a lot more
real and a lot more
personal for daku daku begs his
classmates to get away from him and just
let him leave
but before he can escape he runs into a
wall of ice
created by todoroki todoroki tells deku
that he must let them share his burden
he can't keep trying to carry the weight
of the entire world on his
own shoulders and this is what i've been
talking about for a while now
all of deku's class 1a classmates are
also working hard to become heroes he's
not the only one
and heroes are prepared to take risks in
order to do good and
save innocent people yes it is risky to
stay with deku while he is being
targeted by villains
but his classmates are heroes in the
making and they are prepared to take
that risk
i don't think that deku realizes just
how risky it is for him to go off on his
own while
all for one and the other villains are
after him if deku is part of a larger
team
it will be harder for the villains to
get to him but if deku is alone
it makes it much more likely that all
for one will find a way to either kill
him
or steal his quirk and if they lose deku
it is game over for the heroes so yeah i
think that deku's current thinking is
really short-sighted and he needs to
stop being so damn stubborn
then after that high-flying scene with
deku trying to escape and todoroki
stopping him with a wall of ice
freaking froppy shows up and just melts
all of our hearts
froppy doesn't try to restrain deku
physically or anything like that
she just tells daku that she won't let
him go because she doesn't want to cry
like she did back then when she says
back then she's referring to the time
when class 1a was bitterly divided
over whether they should try to rescue
bakugo on their own
or not tsuyu tells deku that he is
important he is important to all of them
and he is allowed to be scared and shed
tears that is how one becomes a true
hero like heroes and comics
not by pretending that you are
superhuman and that you don't have any
emotions
but by dealing with your emotions and
accepting the help and support of others
like every human being must at some
point in their lives
whether they're a hero or not as tsuyu
tells deku that they won't let him go
alone
this extremely emotional chapter ends
and this chapter really drove home the
point of just how stubborn and
short-sighted deku can be
you could definitely compare him to all
might and how allmight
always wanted to put up this brave front
for the people and how he always pushed
himself beyond his limits because he
felt
personally responsible for everything
and everyone
but it was exactly this type of behavior
that eventually led to all might
sustaining severe injuries
at the hands of all for one injuries
that eventually forced him
into retirement and on top of that when
all might did retire
the hero society basically collapsed
because everyone was used to just
trusting all might to take care of
everything
so when all might wasn't around anymore
the people lost faith
in the hero society as much as deku
idolizes all might
he needs to learn from all might's
mistakes he needs to accept the help of
his friends he needs to share
the burden and he needs to think long
term
deku can't help anyone if he pushes
himself too far and ends up severely
injured or dead
i don't know about you guys but i'm
definitely rooting for class 1a
at this point i think that they really
need to talk some sense into deku
and if they can't talk sent into him
they might need to beat some sense into
him
and i feel like bakugo is just about
ready to do exactly that
so what do you guys think is going to
happen next as i see it there are three
scenarios that could potentially unfold
scenario one deku manages to get away
and then we're back at square one
with deku pushing himself too hard and
trying to do everything on his own
and his classmates trying to find him
and stop him scenario 2
deku is subdued by his classmates and he
has to accept their help from here on
out
in scenario 3 and this is my favorite
honestly stain shows up
and helps deku escape i can totally see
stain appearing out of nowhere and
threatening to cut
deku's classmates down but then deku
says nah let them go
and let's just get out of here and then
stan and deku can finally join forces
and have their own
sitcom where they become quirky
roommates who fight crime and break
all the rules okay maybe the sitcom is a
step too far but you know what i mean
there is a reason why stane was shown
basically spying on daku back in chapter
317. he will definitely make an
appearance at some point in the near
future
and it would be cool if that happens
during this confrontation between deku
and class
1a i mean just imagine deku choosing to
go with stain
over his class 1a comrades that would be
so crazy
and yet it would kind of make sense at
this point in the story don't forget to
let me know what you guys thought about
this confrontation between deco and
class 1a
and what do you think is going to happen
next let me know down below
if you enjoyed this pocono hero video
and you want to see more
leave a like to let me know it only
takes a second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor make this the video that
you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you really have to go through the
trouble of subscribing hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos even
if you are subscribed it's just how
youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
animeopror thanks again to nab new for
sponsoring this video
check them out link in the description
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you